un bilan humain bien plus terrible
qu'anoncé le 16 mars dernier le théâtre
de Mario Paul est détruit par une frappe
russe alors que plusieurs centaines de
civils y sont réfugiés comme cette femme
qui témoigne par téléphone
l'explosion a été terrible tout est
devenu très confus
je n'arrivais plus à distinguer les gens
autour de moi à cause de la poussière
mon mari est monté à l'étage pour voir
ce qu'il se passait et il a commencé à
crier il disait qu'il y avait des corps
partout
combien était-il exactement quelques
heures après le drame les autorités de
la ville avancent un premier bilan qui
fait état de 300 morts mais une nouvelle
enquête associatite presse démontre que
près de 600 personnes auraient été tuées
dans l'explosion soit le double du bilan
annoncé pour en arriver à cette
conclusion les journalistes ont réalisé
une reconstitution de l'intérieur des
lieux grâce à des plans du théâtre des
vidéos amateurs et le témoignage de 23
personnes survivants et secouristes tous
ceux qui se trouvaient dans les étages
supérieurs sont morts ce sont ceux qui
se cachaient loin des fenêtres ils
étaient dans les pièces du haut au
deuxième et au troisième étage c'est là
qu'il vivait quand le missile a frappé
ils ont dû être tués sur le coup puis le
bâtiment entier s'est effondré et
beaucoup de débris sont tombés dans les
étages inférieurs où il y avait aussi
beaucoup de monde à ce jour la Russie
dément toujours avoir bombardé le
théâtre